es geht sozusagen ungeimpften an den
kragen die bundesregierung macht
ordentlich druck auf ungeimpfte auf die
millionen deutschen die sich bisher
nicht impfen lassen wollten es gibt eine
testpflicht für ungeimpfte sowie es
theresa gerade gesagt habe ab der
inzidenz 35 für restaurant in besucher
für fitnessstudios für friseure auch für
hotels muss regelmäßig wenn sie ins
hotel gehen in die pension gehen
regelmäßig getestet werden für konzerte
für sportveranstaltungen und und und
also das leben wird schwerer auch
bewusst erschwert offenbar für
ungeimpfte das hat bild vize barons aber
bei uns im studio vor allen dingen
markus söder gerade klar gemacht bayerns
ministerpräsident der ganz klar sagt ein
weg in die freiheit gibt es für
ungeimpfte derzeit nicht bzw nur mit
tests zur ist die sky ich habe das ganze
oder ich empfinde die regierung sowie
sich dort präsentiert hat als eine die
im daueralarm modus ist obwohl sich die
situation verändert hat behält sie die
gleichen tänzern man will nicht
umschwenken man will keine weiteren
werte mit reinnehmen das sehen wir zum
beispiel bei der festlegung ab wann
diese testpflicht gelten soll nämlich
bei 35 residenz 35 und da fragt man sich
warum ist das so wir haben doch dazu
gelernt diese institute sagt doch nicht
vielmehr aus also da hat die kanzlerin
noch einmal sehr technisch in der
pressekonferenz erklärt warum aus ihrer
sicht das dringend notwendig ist vorher
hat sie noch darauf verwiesen in der
sitzung wie dramatisch doch die zahlen
steigen also es hat sich in ihrer
rhetorik nichts verändert und am ende
auch an ihrer ansatzweise an der weise
wie sie mit corona umgeht und wie sie
dagegen kämpft in ihrer handlung nichts
verändert das finde ich problematisch
noch problematischer finde ich wie sich
markus söder geäußert hat der bayerische
ministerpräsident
der hat dann in einer art ja alarme
panik ansprache gesagt das ist eine
trügerische ruhe dass eine vierte welle
die kommt die pandemie der ungeimpften
stellt vor uns er hat von delta
gesprochen den mutationen und ungeimpfte
die eben die probleme haben die sie
haben also er ist in der gleichen
rhetorik geblieben der letzten anders
jahre auch er hat sich nie verändert in
seiner sicht darauf sondern so klar muss
man es formulieren wird am ende panik
dass wir vor einer neuen horrorzahl
stehen könnten nämlich er sagt wenn es
nicht endlich mehr geimpfte in
deutschland gibt und die politiker reden
gar nicht dran vorbei am ende ist es
eine klare impfpflicht durch die
hintertür dadurch dass das etwas kostet
dadurch dass man druck auslöst dadurch
dass man sagt es wird alles ganz schlimm
möchte man druck auslösen dass es mehr
gifte gibt dann als dritter im bunde der
regierende bürgermeister herr müller der
dann gesagt hat um gottes willen ja die
bürger nehmen die info angebote nicht an
da frage ich mich doch ja warum tut er
denn nicht endlich was warum geht er
raum gehen seine mitarbeiter nicht
endlich dorthin wo es weh tut warum
siehst du dich in den brennpunkten warum
sind sie nicht dort wo es milieus gibt
die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen
warum gibt es keine bessere kampagne
also dass klagen dass die panikmache der
alarm modus das reicht nicht mehr man
wünscht sich einen politiker der anpackt
und sagt okay ich nehme jetzt die leute
aus meiner stadtverwaltung gehe dahin
und wir versuchen einfach jeden
einzelnen dort zu impfen wo es möglich
ist und das zieht sich durch die
gesamten beschlüsse der regierung ich
empfinde das als eine art daueralarm
modus der sich nicht verändert hat wenn
daueralarm modus markus söder selbst hat
gerade von einer endlosschleife
gesprochen für ungeimpfte die eben
keinen ausweg mehr finden aus einer
solchen endlosschleife außerdem
regelmäßigen testen das betrifft
friseure hotels betrifft eben auch
großveranstaltungen
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier und vergiss bitte nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren